[Music]
holy technician it's Rebecca Albert here
cat Alvarado of mama funny my funny
friend she is going to be in New York
next week guys if you guys are into East
Coast make sure to catch her she will be
performing comedy at a few venues off
the top of my head November 5th & 6th at
6 p.m. at the Eastvale comedy club
November 7 at 8:30 at the Mockingbird
and November 8th at juvenile to boots
Brooklyn at 8 p.m. juvenile delinquents
[Laughter]
at 8 p.m. at the comedy cove Scotty's in
Springfield New Jersey catch her there
guys all that's in the description box
hey do you like Matt Damon
do you like Matt Damon yeah he's pretty
cool yeah this new movie called
downsizing which actually looks really
good I like office space it is not
office space I could tell you that much
I thought it was gonna be an office time
for the movie and then you realize what
they actually mean by downsizing is just
wait till you see
[Music]
[Music]
big Steve Johnson he never struck me as
the kind of guy to focus so the decision
to downsize thing takes the pressure
right off especially money pressure you
live like we use your lands where you
want to be permanent and irreversible
[Music]
thinking about yourself or did you can I
[Music]
know those people are pretty big then
anyone self-esteem but downtime thing is
about hitting the reset button start all
over
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
huh that looks good looks like a fun
movie I like the concept of it what I'm
kind of lost on though is what the plot
of the movie is like okay I get it
do you got the world of them being
downsized they become tiny people is it
a story about this guy in this journey
of being this little dude is there then
it seems like there's this mystery
element of like something top secret ago
he seems like a two-layer plot and I
think it's him finding himself again and
purpose after divorce and then there's
also the environmental thing so it
almost makes me wonder if like the
person who wrote it originally wrote
something that was about post their own
divorce and traumatic experience and
then executives really we don't want to
buy it there's no hook and they're like
what if we were tiny the last half of it
seemed to go a little bit all over the
place in terms of its he's trying to
help people out who are dying and then
there's some top-secret thing going on
he's trying to explore his life
everything's big there's so much going
on the first trailer send a lot more
contain and I didn't see it but it was
just like a fun like cute trailer and
they didn't reveal that Kristen Wiig
doesn't get downsized in the last
trailer for me it was a mistake because
I'm a huge Kristen Wiig and I was like
this movie's gotta be awesome and then
I'm like oh oh she's gonna be in it for
a lot of it yeah and I suddenly like
went from a 10 to a 4 that was a funny
moment though we're only one eye Robbie
favorite shows she like I feel like this
might get unnecessarily dark and when I
like more of the upbeat vibe I don't
know you know it's kind of film you got
to wait to really find out what you see
this is just kind of my prediction
feelings I get the impression that the
first half will be a lot more enjoyable
than the last half I see this movie it's
like a second tier movie like you make
your list of things are gonna see this
season that movies are out we just
reviewed I Tania for me I'm like okay
that's at the top for me and then it's
like if I see one or two other movies
this would be number three or it'd be
like okay what else this looks like it
might get totally confusing wait he's
doing drugs
and then with all the health problems
the first trailer made me feel like this
is gonna be a delight this one made me
feel more along the lines of I don't
know if I'm gonna enjoy it as much as I
thought I was okay here's the plot felt
like it's something more geared
scrapping the little people part it
feels like it's geared towards people
who are like in their 40s having a
midlife crisis and the writer/director
tends to do those kinds of times but my
mom hates science fiction I don't know
if anybody else's parent is like that
but I feel like it would be towards
people who are like our parents yeah
kind of if they're not into wild and
wacky things the way we are it might
just be like a Miss I really can't tell
how this film will do there are some
trailers you seen you're like this one's
gonna be good it's gonna be a success
and then the shows like this or on I
have no idea people hurt actually gonna
tune in for this movie but I think it's
probably gonna be good it's probably
gonna be broken just think it's gonna
miss the mark on its intended audience
cuz I don't even think the movie knows
who it's intended is I slap a bunch of
famous people on they're throwing some
jokes in the trailer little people great
visual effects what I was thinking
though was I could and because of
YouTube guidelines but not to be clever
with my words I was thinking it would be
fun to get downsized and inhale some
stuff out of a pipe some green leafy
things out of a pipe a human-sized pipe
but as a miniature person how much money
would I say one hit a day I'm golden all
day long the first trailer was more
about that the what if like what are the
advantages and then the first shot
really explores that you're like man
that looks cool this one made it look
like this looks like a horrible idea
maybe not I don't think this is a good
Oh like when you do the downsizing yeah
that seems like a plot hole gender this
is different gender mmm I don't know I
would want to be there with my
significant other and that would prevent
something
putting like this where you guys go and
you do it and then one person doesn't do
it that's a plot hole more like a
personal preference that you have in
this fictional city my idea all right
guys well hey December 22nd are you
gonna go catch this movie put it in the
comment subscribe to the reel rejects
please click that notification bell
become a patron inject today on patreon
more importantly though make sure to
follow Kat Alvarado on all the social
media links in the description box and
if you're in the East Coast make sure to
catch her out there performing comedy
live next week and if you're in LA just
follow her on Facebook and she usually
post when she'll be performing and who
knows maybe I'll be there too